hey everybody it's great to be back in
the studio we had the fourth of july
holiday over the weekend and it's not
it's not really feeling like a great
time to be proud
about being an american or living in the
united states and it's only getting
worse
as restrictions on where americans are
allowed to go around the world continue
to grow
we talked uh i mean listen i said months
ago that
it's likely that as other countries get
coronavirus under control
and we don't because of our failed
incompetent leadership
we will not be allowed to participate in
the travel that is now becoming
commonplace in other parts of the world
uh and case in point the united states
is included in a list of countries
from which people cannot travel to
europe despite europe
being widely reopened spoke to friends
in france and belgium over the weekend
and you know they're taking precautions
masks on public transit but restaurants
are open things are happening people are
traveling between european countries
americans not
allowed to go there it's getting even
worse now
the mexican state of sonora has closed
the border
to the united states specifically their
borders with the state of arizona ahead
of the july fourth weekend the governor
of sonora saying that american travelers
are not going to be allowed to come in
there's too much of a risk with
coronavirus being
rampant in arizona and in the united
states they don't want americans on
sonoran beaches
july 4th is a peak tourism time for
americans going over there now before we
go even further
is anybody else a little bit confused
about
going to another country to celebrate
our
independence day i mean i guess
conceptually if you just think about it
as
time off then you go wherever there's no
rule that says you have to stay in the
united states but it is interesting that
in a state like arizona
which is not a particularly progressive
state there would be so much desire
on our independence day to leave the
country
and to go to mexico i guess if you're
under 21 it makes more sense because you
can drink in mexico and not in the
united states legally anyway but there's
something about that that's maybe a
little bit counter-intuitive
but in any case in any case americans
not allowed
to cross the border from arizona into
sonora a reopening date
has not yet been announced and it's just
too dangerous americans are a danger
to mexico mexico having its own fair
share of troubles controlling
coronavirus but arizona
one of the global hot spots at this
point never mind
one of the american hot spots the growth
rate of cases in arizona
one of one of the largest in the world
and
it does seem i mean listen i understand
why they're doing it i don't like that
we can't travel to europe
i had a trip to europe planned in june
obviously it was canceled i was hoping
that i could reschedule it to august
i haven't and it doesn't look like
that's going to be even remotely safe so
i'm not going to do it so
from a personal perspective i don't like
it but
you have to imagine that a lot of the
people going from arizona to mexico for
the fourth of july
during a pandemic are not going to be
what we would call our best to borrow a
term from donald trump it's probably
the anti-massacres maybe anti-vaxxers as
well conspiracy theorists the so-called
liberty people
maybe birthers truthers of different
persuasions trumpists and gun people
q anons and of course because of the
virus
probably some coveted people as well
because who else would really be doing
for unnecessary foreign travel right now
as dr anthony fauci recently said
he would only get onto an airplane in an
emergency right now so the numbers in
arizona
are horrifying 98 000 total cases
probably by the end of today
arizona will be at 100 000 total cases
approaching 2000 deaths very fast growth
rate peak death number so far in arizona
was just a few days ago july 1st is the
day on which arizona has had the most
single day deaths
and looking at case numbers it would not
be shocking that they best that in the
next few days
sonora in mexico the state of sonora
their hospitals are filling up
their testing capacity is limited they
can't afford a spike
so they're saying sorry americans you
can't come here
so parts of mexico are now closed to
americans
the canadian border is closed except for
essential travel with mandatory
quarantine
can't fly to europe they wanted
nationalism we're sort of weirdly
getting this isolationist
nationalism not exactly by our choice
but
happening as a result of other countries
instituting limitations on americans
the optimistic hopeful scenario right
now
i don't want to blow smoke anywhere you
know up down wherever it is you don't
want smoke blown i don't want to blow it
um but the optimistic scenario right now
is biden defeats trump when he takes
over in january
we likely still have a huge mess
hopefully by then there's an early
vaccine there's initial vaccine access
by january i think optimistic would be
healthcare workers and some of the most
vulnerable
and it will still probably be six months
beyond that of biden
focusing heavily on coronavirus
to really get things under control
economically and medically we're going
to talk about the economic component in
a little bit
and of course a lot of this will depend
on republican obstruction which is why
taking control of the senate in november
in addition to removing donald trump
is so clearly important and because
we're here for the full week this week
no days off this week
later this week i'm going to revisit the
topic of the senate which i think is a
really important one